[Música]
comienza con una tos o una sibilancia
pronto siente el pecho apretado su
respiración se acelera y se vuelve más
superficial y hace que sienta que le
falta el aire Estos son síntomas comunes
de un ataque de asma
en todo el mundo más de 300 millones de
personas sufren de asma y alrededor de
250.000 personas mueren por asma cada
año Pero por qué la gente tiene asma y
por qué esta enfermedad puede ser mortal
el asma afecta el sistema respiratorio
particularmente las vías aéreas más
pequeñas como los bronquios y los
bronquiolos estas vías respiratorias
tienen un revestimiento interno llamado
mucosa rodeado por una capa de músculo
liso
las personas con asma tienen las vías
respiratorias crónicamente inflamadas lo
que los hace hiperreactivos ante ciertos
desencadenantes algunos de los
desencadenantes del asma son el humo del
tabaco el polen el polvo los perfumes el
ejercicio el clima frío el estrés y
hasta un resfrío común cuando las
personas con asma están expuestas a
estos desencadenantes puede darse un
ataque de asma o su exacerbación
pero como Estos factores cotidianos
llevan a un ataque de asma si un
asmático está expuesto a un
desencadenante los Anillos lisos del
músculo que circundan las pequeñas vías
respiratorias en sus pulmones se
contraen y estrechan el desencadenante
empeora la inflamación Al hacer que el
revestimiento de la mucosa se hinche más
y secrete más mucosidad
bajo condiciones normales el cuerpo
Utiliza este moco para atrapar y limpiar
las partículas como el polen o el polvo
pero durante un ataque de asma bloquea
las vías respiratorias estrechadas
haciendo aún más difícil respirar
estos efectos llevan a estos síntomas
del asma la constricción del músculo
liso da la sensación de opresión en el
pecho el exceso de moco y el aumento de
la inflamación pueden causar tos las
vigilancias ocurren porque al contraerse
las vías respiratorias el aire silba al
pasar a través del espacio estrecho
estos síntomas hacen que una persona
sienta que se está quedando sin aire sin
embargo durante un ataque de asma la
inflamación puede hacer más difícil
exhalar que inhalar con el tiempo esto
conduce a un exceso de aire en los
pulmones un fenómeno conocido como
hiperinflación el atrapamiento de aire
en los pulmones obliga al cuerpo a
trabajar más duro para mover el aire
dentro y fuera de ellos con el tiempo
esto puede reducir el envío de oxígeno a
los órganos y tejidos
a veces en los ataques de asma graves no
tratados el cuerpo no lo puede aguantar
lo que puede llevar a la muerte por
falta de oxígeno pero Cómo podemos
evitar estos ataques potencialmente
mortales en personas con asma
una forma es reducir la presencia de
desencadenantes Lamentablemente El mundo
es un lugar impredecible y la exposición
a desencadenantes no siempre se puede
controlar aquí es donde entran los
inhaladores el tratamiento primario para
el asma estos medicamentos ayudan a
controlar y prevenir los síntomas los
inhaladores transportan medicamentos a
las vías respiratorias afectadas usando
una Niebla líquida o polvo fino para
tratar el problema en su origen vienen
en dos formas hay medicamentos de alivio
que tratan los síntomas inmediatamente y
contienen Beta agonistas Los Beta
agonistas relajan los músculos
estrechados ensanchando las vías
respiratorias para que más aire pueda
entrar y salir de los pulmones otros
inhaladores sirven como medicamentos
preventivos tratando los síntomas del
asma a largo plazo y contienen
corticosteroides
estos reducen la sensibilidad e
inflamación de las vías respiratorias y
mantienen el asma bajo control también
son cruciales para prevenir daños por la
inflamación Crónica que puede causar
cicatrices en las vías respiratorias los
inhaladores son muy eficaces y ayudan a
tener mayor calidad de vida
a pesar del largo camino recorrido para
mejorar como tratamos y diagnosticamos
el asma todavía no conocemos sus causas
exactas
hoy se cree que participa una
combinación de factores genéticos y
ambientales durante la primera infancia
investigadores recientes han relacionado
a la pobreza con los ataques de asma
esto puede deberse a la exposición a
contaminantes e irritantes ambientales y
a dificultades en la obtención de
atención o tratamiento médico a medida
que mejora la comprensión del asma
Seguiremos encontrando mejores formas de
tener vías respiratorias saludables
otra afección que afecta a millones de
personas en todo el mundo es la caspa
Entonces qué causa la caspa y hay alguna
forma de tratarla con este video Explore
este problema que provoca rascarse la
cabeza